how embarrassing you caught me drinking
my breakfast afternoon coffee and eating
my breakfast afternoon lunchable this is
what heaven looks like no no no you know
your life is different now I opened up a
lunchable as an adult and I very
sincerely and intentionally started
eating it as a meal and then I got a
notification that my doorbell was to
bring cake and guess what showed up and
hello fresh showing up this is bad
but like I could do better it was like
the universe swatted this out of my hand
presented me with a new option for body
fuel and then I decided to turn the
camera on well I decided to put makeup
on my face and then turn the camera on
because as much as I want to be
authentic I'm a little insecure merch
link in the description below let's make
a video hello fresh by the grace of God
has allowed me to make videos every
month on their behalf showing you how
cool they I don't know if I've done them
a service or disservice
but like the cheese is all conglomerated
together like play-doh a lunchable and
coffee
we're just fresh up from an adderall
Center for my midterm oh that's a bad
pairing if you guys don't know I've been
working with hold fresh all year every
month I'm showing you how to cook one of
the recipes that they send to me to
prove that idiots like me can do it and
that means that you can probably slam
Siri and/or Alexa Google Image Search
domestic goddess psych you don't need to
it's right here
who do you think Syrian Alexa get along
oh my god do you think they're frenemies
you think they don't talk to each other
every now and then like you're doing a
good job and then behind the scenes
they're like you're talking to ask G use
in there like she's such a [ __ ] that's
a thought for another time okay here's a
fun view be in a couple hours I'm on my
way to go back to New Jersey to surprise
my mom for her birthday she's gonna be
very excited and hopefully it works out
I'm taking a red-eye to New Jersey and I
only have literally like an hour I
figured now is the best time the most
like fun stressful time to make one of
these hellofresh meals and guess what
we're making today special effects
slam dunk what it i'm dizziest chicken
cheddar
but he does I do have a lactose
sensitivity and I'm gonna test out for
you and then get on a metal tube and go
celebrate my mother's bird let's do this
today hella fresh is a subscription meal
delivery service and they have talking
points that are more articulate than
what I can tell you about them off the
top of my head how fresh does all the
meal prep ring shopping and planning so
you can something something something
why is my brain off hello fresh is all
the meal hello fresh does all the meal
prepping shopping and planning so you
can focus on a healthier you and a
happier family all right
Oh nailed it hello fresh gives you these
giant cue cards or like flash cards
basically that give you six steps to
make their recipe they have photos and
they have words are what they're called
words and if you watched any of these
videos in the past at some point I
thought to place your bets on which step
one through six that I will ultimately
be up first now I'm just introducing you
to gambling I'm going to make you that
was the pep talk but God had without a
mini Vegas on refrigerator
smells gross unique its most unique look
at how convenient this is it's like
adult mom packed you an adult lunch
oh it's essentially just an adult
lunchable but it's like you gotyou it
more don't be saying sorry i need the
dogs that are watching this video right
now I can't see how beautifully colorful
this is step 1 prep and pre-heat your
oven to 400 degrees wouldn't it be funny
if that was many degrees is first we're
doing a entitle wash and dry off produce
oh you don't have to wash the I guess
this mother F P on thinly slice the
onion I hope my neighbor's all just
looked in on me right now doing if you
ever feel upset that people call your
red onion when you're so clearly purple
this is the part where I believe that
I'm a robot because this has no effect
on my eye system at all also that was
normal human cadence right Cordy see you
didn't didn't I slice the bell pepper
everything is great because after this
we get to eat our feelings hi how are
you place bottle bean your hair too thin
round
moving ribs and seeds for less heat I'm
gonna wash my hands because after
touching jalapeno I will do something
bad to my face who knew my house is like
a goddamn EDM concert just half the lime
and then cut it into quarters zesting
means you basically like grate it like
cheese all right I just caught myself
being like extremely educational oh cool
we have zested oh I'll invest in that
do you need change for a dollar cuz I
got quarters officially under step
number two right in this kitchen you
know what that means I only have whiskey
and I feel like an [ __ ]
cooking a small bowl combine jalapeno
and juice from two lime wedges and set
aside two quick pickle the wave of
sexual innuendos that just washed ashore
of my brain while reading the phrase
quick pickle yes overwhelmed juice from
two lime wedges watch yeah y'all quick
pickup we won't look I know it's a
personal thing okay it's okay it's okay
it happens to a lot of jalapenos yeah we
heat a drizzle of oil in a large pan
over medium-high heat and we add onion
bell pepper and half of the Southwest
spice would you look this a convenient
it comes the goddamn pack of Southwest
way and then we cook stirring until
softened and lightly charred for four to
five minutes and then we season with
salt and pepper and we remove from the
pan and we set it aside if I can't
relate to being seasoned and set aside
I don't know now we're gonna step three
you know what that means yes now we make
our crema which again I'm sorry for in a
second Smallville get mine our sour
cream and bean Lee comes in like a
go-gurt looking to go burr is disgusting
you're putting like sweet mayonnaise
into your mouth hole
I know goose yeah thank you for your
support that were greeting Oh God a
squeeze r2 of lime juice add lime zest
then we had a oh my god okay
I'm panicking Oh and then we stir in
water I've never heard of it I probably
should drink it from time to time a
drizzling consistent oh it's no longer a
drizzling consistency it's like a
stagnant pool but let's season with salt
and pepper
step four I haven't fully pushed up yet
so we're gonna cook the chicken place
the chicken into strips season with salt
and pepper heat a large drizzle of oil
in the pan used for the veggies over
medium-high heat add the chicken and
cook for like two to four minutes and
then
in the veggies and the remaining
Southwest spice and continued cook until
the chicken is browned and cooked
through two to three more minutes I had
a pea do you have to let's all take a
break for a second don't wanna step 5
we need a baking sheet whatever then a
pants you know say when she stopped
giving him
I don't give a baking sheet we're
supposed to place our tortillas on a
baking sheet in a single layer and
sprinkle evenly with cheddar then we
bake until the cheese is melted for one
to two minutes you and I don't get along
but I can't resist you mother ok one or
two minutes oh ok sorry
I feel disconnected from you how are you
have you burned any bridges this week
let me know in the comments down below I
think it's time for step six it's time
to divide the chicken mixture drizzle
the back and then put the bat on it here
we go sorry before we go I forgot to
mention that there's three meal plan
options there's classic veggie family
and you can always change up if your
tastes change and I just want you to
know that and now I'm gonna make this
plate look so goddamn gorgeous that
you're gonna want to hear about the
promo code I have for you I don't know
why more vloggers don't use this angle
this is great I look like a head from
Easter Island this actual pornography
I'm gonna get goddamn flag this is what
our tinder profile picture looks like
this is how she shows up and that's a
girl you want to party with hell yeah
you guys get a tasty treat and that is
eight free meals if you are interested
in hella fresh
go to hello fresh com eight free meals
your first month when you sign up that's
$80 off your first month if you use the
promo code grace helbig 80 again hello
fresh com promo code grace helbig baby
also hello fresh makes meals from $6.99
now we taste I know it seems like I'm
putting this on but I'm not that's
really good I love fresh it's like that
friend that you get
they're gonna give you such a vote of
confidence to believe that you have more
capabilities than you truly do yes you
damn that's really good and super easy
thank you guys so much for watching this
video I love making these I hope you do
too if you do and give it a thumbs up
all the information for the hellofresh
tails in the description box below get
that Bell notification however YouTube
it's decided that you can do it because
you're gonna want to get notified about
when I make videos because I make them I
don't know oh by the way my version are
like a cooking show so you and I get to
just kind of like bond and talk candidly
and intimately about like where you have
stuff this week I'll lead the way what
have I picked up on this week I can't
think of anything I've been perfect
repression is a very strong emotion